the DC extended universe has been
struggling to achieve the right tone to
match wits with its marble counterpart
but despite a few hiccups the franchise
doesn't seem to be slowing down anytime
soon Warner Brothers has still got quite
a few new films on the roster for future
development that might just turn things
around once and for all so here's what
DC has in store for superhero movie
lovers next Aquaman
he's been the butt of jokes for years
but James wants Aquaman film looks to
finally bring some respect to the man
who talks to fish of course
casting burly Game of Thrones star Jason
Momoa and the title role didn't hurt the
film will give the eponymous hero a few
central foes including Aquaman's
half-brother the ocean master and
arch-nemesis Black Manta making a
feature-length film about the sea hero
is a risky venture but Wan intends to
breathe new life into the watery comic
character well I think there's a certain
perception with Aquaman and I think part
of the fun would be to some fit that
expectation considering how well he's
handled everything from horror films to
racecar dramas audiences will likely be
in for an action-packed adventure with
this movie hits theaters December 21st
2018 Shazam it's been in the works for
years but for a while there it seemed
like the long-awaited adaptation of
Shazam might never actually come to pass
initial reports had Dwayne Johnson
attached to the film as the villainous
black Adam but DC later revealed that
Johnson's character would get his own
film instead it'll be chuckle um Zachary
Levi who handles the title role with
Annabelle creations David Sandberg
directing the picture Levi has described
the picture as being akin to Tom Hanks
his 1988 comedy favorite big only with
super powers instead of a wish machine I
don't get it the movie is expected to
launch production in 2018 so get ready
to giggle when Shazam hits theaters on
April 5th 2019 Wonder Woman to the first
sequel to the summer smash hit Wonder
Woman was finally given an official
announcement at San Diego comic-con with
the release date set for November 1st
2019 shortly thereafter after months of
keeping fans in the dark
director patty Jenkins confirmed in
early September that she is officially
set to return for the sequel and rumors
suggest her salary could be historic
we will protect it until 9:00 Jenkins
and DC studio head Geoff Johns are
teaming up with the Expendables Dave
Callaham to work on the script based on
a treatment from Jenkins and jobs with
Jenkins saying she wants to take Dianna
to America and rumors saying the film
could take place in the 1980s Wonder
Woman - seems like it will be an amazing
ride and now that embattled producer
Brett Ratner is out of the picture gal
gadot is officially a go for it - Oh
Green Lantern Corps the Green Lantern
has certainly had a rough history in
Hollywood with the Ryan Reynolds led
adaptation arriving as a laughingstock
in 2011 but DC isn't done trying to make
Hal Jordan happen David Goyer and Justin
Rhodes are working on a script to revive
the fallen franchise with plans for the
film to take flight on July 24th 2020
there's no word yet on the plot of the
new take but it has been described as
Lethal Weapon in space and is reportedly
based on a comic book origin story we
also know it'll focus on two different
characters the popular lanterns Hal
Jordan and Jon Stewart
bringing Stewart in is a wise move since
he's a fan favorite and getting him in
the mix will help this film stand apart
from its predecessor flashpoint DC's
flash movie starring Ezra Miller as
Barry Allen has had a bit of a rocky
road the film first found a director in
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies Seth
grahame-smith but he dropped out and was
followed by Rick FAMU uh who also left
rumors have put Matthew Vaughn Robert
Zemeckis and Sam Raimi in the mix
although it's unclear as of the making
of this video if talks are moving
forward with any of them the script has
also undergone quite a few rewrites with
reports saying it was being completely
overhauled concrete details about the
film finally began to be released at
this year's Comic Con when DC officially
announced that the movie would be titled
flashpoint this seems to suggest that
the movie will cover the famous 2011
comic storyline which is a move that
could have huge ripple effects across
the rest of the DC EU Miller has been a
consistent favorite in everything he's
appeared in so far so the pressure is on
to get the speedy superhero to the
theaters sooner than later
okay cyborg by the time cyborg shows up
in his solo movie fans should be pretty
familiar with them relax Alfred don't
take it from here do I know you
after making half a cameo in Batman vs
Superman Ray Fischer's version of the
character will appear in Justice League
and will appear in flashpoint while
details are still slim as to what his
solo movie will entail Fischer has said
that if he had his pick of the
villainous litter as to who he'll fight
it it be the phantom limbs the Batman
Batman has long been the cash cow of the
DC Universe but as much as Warner
Brothers wants to get a standalone movie
going with Ben Affleck's version of The
Dark Knight the project has been very
troubled not only have there been
numerous script rewrites and Affleck
stepping back from the director's chair
he's now said to want a cool way to
escape the cape altogether he since
clarified that he's still planning to
take the role but reports on his
commitment to being the Caped Crusader
have given DC fans a bit of whiplash
meanwhile the film has tapped war for
the planet of the apes matt reeves to
take the helm and he supposedly got a
guy in mind to take over for Affleck if
the situation calls for it whether
batfleck takes flight again or not Joe
Manganiello steth stroke is expected to
be the central villain which should make
for one beefy Bonanza indeed dark
universe also known as Justice League
dark dark universe is set to focus on
the mystical side of things with
characters such as John Constantine
Swamp Thing Deadman
Zatanna and Etrigan the demon edge of
tomorrow doug liman was initially signed
on to direct but he dropped out due to
scheduling conflicts and the film has
yet to find a new director as script
changes are underway considering the
success Marvel had with its similarly
otherworldly Doctor Strange it stands to
reason Warner Brothers will be keen to
get this one off the bench soon Gotham
City sirens while Suicide Squad - is
also in the barrel David Ayer will first
tackle this Harley Quinn centric
spin-off with Margot Robbie and other
female heroes and villains across the DC
Comics Canon called the Gotham City
sirens
but no word on which characters will
show up though players like Catwoman and
poison ivy seem like prime candidates
along with getting a Wonder Woman movie
out before Marvel could make Captain
Marvel DC has an excellent opportunity
to take the edge and female lead
superhero fare which could be a huge
move for a studio playing catch-up that
is as long as the movies are good I'm
known to be quite vexing I'm just
forewarning you Justice League to Warner
Brothers originally penciled this one in
for 2019 though it's since been bumped
to an unspecified date to clear out some
space for the Batman but of all the
projects at the far end of DC's master
plan it stands to reason another Justice
League is one of the most bankable the
Avengers has become a flagship franchise
for Marvel and DC is looking to leverage
Justice League the same way it'll just
have to wait until after a couple of
standalone films Man of Steel - it's the
worst-kept secret in movie history that
Superman Returns for the Justice League
film despite the events of dawn of
Justice but the studio doesn't seem to
be in a major hurry to give him another
solo adventure even though Man of Steel
was technically the inaugural
installment of this franchise the cast
has confirmed the script is in the works
but with so many other movies on the
docket it could be years until they
actually get around to making this one
but when they do it'll surely be a brave
new adventure for the Big Blue Boy Scout
Suicide Squad - a proper Suicide Squad
sequel is in development but there's
been no word on when it'll actually hit
the big screen
despite terrible reviews the first film
still made a whole lot of money and
introduced characters like Robbie's
Harley Quinn and Will Smith's Deadshot
you might want to work on your team
motivation thing the accountants Gavin
O'Connor has officially signed on to
direct and rewrite the script so with a
behind the scenes team finally coming
together it looks like the rumored fall
of 2018 production start date isn't so
unreasonable after all Nightwing the
Lego Batman movies Chris McKay will take
on live-action superheroes in DC's plan
Nightwing movie the film is being
scripted by the accountants Bill Dubuque
and although it doesn't have a star yet
the acrobatic shoes of Dick Grayson are
going to be fun to fill because
according to McKay he's not going to be
relying on CGI to make his quote badass
action movie happened better
after taking over the helm of Justice
League from Zack Snyder joss whedon will
next write direct and produce an
adaptation of Batgirl for the DC EU the
title role is rumored to follow the new
52 version of Barbara Gordon and offer a
darker version of the character
storyline featuring her using
experimental surgery to recover from a
severe spinal injury inflicted by the
Joker with the amazing success of Wonder
Woman it makes sense the DC is pursuing
Batgirl and it wouldn't be surprising to
see them push the movie ahead quickly
lobo word leaked last year that Warner
Brothers is looking to bring the space
Bounty Hunter Lobo to the DC EU after a
Guy Ritchie adaptation fell through a
few years back and Wonder Woman's Jason
Fuchs is reportedly working on the
script now the new project is apparently
a fresh take on the character and
considering the success Fox and Marvel
have had with Deadpool Lobo could be a
foul-mouthed sweet spot for DC to get in
on the four-letter action to Deadshot
Will Smith is a Hollywood star so it's
no surprise Warner Brothers is looking
to spin him off with a film focused on
his Suicide Squad character Deadshot
outside of Ben Affleck Smith is arguably
the biggest star in the DC EU so it's
only a matter of time until they get him
suited back up for another fight against
Batman even so the project is still very
early on in development so no release
date has been established just yet Black
Adam Dwayne the rock Johnson has been
attached to co-star in a Shazam movie
for years playing the villain black Adam
but Warner Brothers is now developing a
full-fledged Black Adam spin-off film
which will split the character off into
more of an antihero it remains to be
seen how DC will juggle a two-pronged
side section of the DC EU while they're
still trying to establish the main
universe but in the meantime we've done
a little Photoshop to imagine how
Johnson will look in character Joker's
origin story the Joker is one of DC's
most popular characters so it makes
sense that they're taking yet another
stab at bringing him to the big screen
and this time with a planned solo movie
about the characters origins the movie
is said to explore what it took for the
Joker to become a criminal mastermind
using an ad setting as a backdrop while
it will obviously draw heavily from the
comic books it's supposedly intended to
feel more like a gritty crime drama than
a superhero film and is said to be
separate from any other iteration of the
Joker in the DC
you the movie is set to be co-written
and directed by the hangovers todd
phillips with the fighters scott silver
joining his co-writer don't expect to
see jared leto in the lead phillips
apparently wants to recast the Suicide
Squad star which makes sense considering
the movies different time period and
separation from the rest of DC's films
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Martin Scorsese is attached to the film
as a producer and sources say that
Warner Brothers is looking to secure
Leonardo DiCaprio for the role of the
Joker in response to the rumored casting
possibility artist Roy Ledger drew some
amazing concept art of what a DiCaprio
Joker would look like Joker and Harley
Quinn's movie Jared Leto is however
expected to reprise his role alongside
Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn in their
own film which has been described as
When Harry Met Sally on Benzedrine to
that end the studio has recruited a duo
familiar with romance with this is us as
glenn ficarra and john requa and final
talks to write and direct the pair also
already have experience working with
robbie having directed her in both focus
and whiskey-tango-foxtrot while the
movie doesn't have a release date yet it
could be on the way soon insiders say
the plan is to fast-track the movie
after the upcoming Suicide Squad - with
the timeline being pushed up thanks to
the actress holding agreements while it
may seem like we're getting Joker
overload with the Suicide Squad sequel
and the characters planned origin story
movie this film is said to be further
along
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to